there must be some aspect of the Tipsy
situation that I don't understand even
even if I'm on the losing side of a
fight I still want to go down swinging
I could tell how much this affected
Jocko it would suck to be so close to
such an unjust fight and not be able to
do anything about it yes it it is hard
to look at that situation and really
understand it then it's horrible look
back at it now and know that we didn't
do anything about it but but what can we
do with it how can we apply this to
everyday life because I agree with you
you gotta go down swinging and I'll tell
you this if you if you fight with all
you've got more often than not you won't
go down at all you win but you got to
make that attitude part of your everyday
life the extra rep the extra mile the
extra round the right choices to make
yourself stronger mentally and
physically stand and fight fight against
weakness and against fear then fight
against time and decay fight back go
down to swinging give every day
everything you've got and when you face
a challenge even something where you
don't believe you can win maybe it's a
situation where you cannot win but if
you can
when remember this you have nothing to
lose so stand up and go forward and go
out in a blaze of glory fighting with
everything you've got every ounce of
energy every beat is sweat and every
drop of blood until your last breath and
then and only then you can stand down
you can put down your sword and you can
put down your shield and rest in peace